hey everyone it's Jonah here how is
everybody coping at home well I hope you
aren't spending too much time sitting on
about every single day if you have a
chair get up and do this 30 minutes
chair workout with me okay it is great
to be low-impact it's great for
beginners but it's great to tone and
sculpt your entire body okay let's start
with an easy warm-up we want to use our
chair okay so what are we to do is give
me 10 squats stand up and reach down
have your butt on to the chair alright
so you want to be pushing your butt back
for those of you who are new to
squatting this is actually a really good
way to perfect your squats so remember
your butt should be touching the chair
but good push it back slow it down up
squeeze again back down and squeeze
so we're warming up the lower body
because we want to be working a lot on
the lower body for the first circuit
keep going not three more tap down up
and last one more and good okay sit on
your chair okay working on our core as
well as warming up the upper body elbow
to knee cross crunch all right so reach
your elbow to your knee on the opposite
side good
so drive your knee up if you can't tap
that's fine okay drive your knee up as
high as you can and cross over and
crunch good so you should feel the work
on your abs as well last two more last
one more cross and very good all right
come back up so we will be using the
chair for the entire workout but we
won't be sitting down okay so the first
six exercises will be working on the
lower body we want to sculpt and tone
the lower body so the first workout is
going to be a
in white squats for those of you who
have done a bard class before this will
be very familiar so what I'm going to do
is stand close together with your toes
pointed out okay take a squat so pretty
buddy wipe step it down again narrow
squat remember to push your knees out
good push your knees out white and down
good so this will work on your thighs as
well as your inner thighs on the white
squat nice if you want to have your
hands by your side and narrow good there
you go
Hank just by your side and in alright
very good last few more working on the
thighs and inner thighs narrow and out
remember to keep your body up right out
and get okay still working on our sides
a little bit more challenge that white
okay
I wait to go tiptoe this is where the
chair will really help with your balance
okay go with tiptoe please our hands in
front just like in a bar class I wanted
to give me squat okay
down and up good push it out and up good
so the work is really on your quads and
your inner thighs good go slow and easy
all the way up all the way down up and
down on your toes if this is too
difficult you can bring your heels down
okay
up and down good keep pointing and
remember to just breathe good push your
knees out last two more put your knees
out and you can feel the work on your
arms as well okay very good
all right so turn the chair around okay
we want to be working on singer Lake
lunch this is a really good quad of the
entire leg the entire thigh workout
basically and it works on your balance
as well okay so place your left foot
behind right fruit on the front okay
what I want to do is lunch down up down
and up again just working on one leg and
really squeeze the gluts right at the
top all right your left leg should be
relaxed the entire work should be on
your right leg remember as you go down
keep your body upright down and up
good push up turn it up very good stay
with me tighten your core find your
balance
that's one more and up okay all right
doing all sorts of things with our chair
okay so place the chair just on again on
the same side bring your right leg up
it's going to be a slight lunch okay so
we're gonna work on our left leg okay so
squat down push up that's it so point
your toes and down and up and down go as
low as you can
working on your left gluts and you
should feel the stretch on your inner
thighs as well very good this is a
single leg side lunge good basically
it's a tougher version of this ended
site lunch go down up so all you need is
a chair to really work on your entire
body down push up up okay remember to
suck your belly in okay very good
alright now grab your chair okay we want
to be supporting ourselves on the head
of the chair okay we want to be working
with kickbacks
so again this is going to target more of
the lower bump alright so step on your
right leg kick all the way back okay
drive the knee in all the way back as
high as you can in and kick it
okay nice and controlled remember to
keep your right knee slightly bent the
standing knee should be bent slightly
good pick it up and down up and down
very good breathe out and breathe in
squeeze right at the top okay
last ten seconds hold here pulse two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
all right okay one final workout and we
want to repeat the entire circuit once
more okay again this is going to be
working on your core and your legs so
it's going to be a combination of knee
to site race all right working on the
outer thighs
ready hands by our waste in the up
pointy toes good point very good
stand tall and point up and point really
working on toning up the lower body up
point up and point okay your goal is to
drive your knee as high as possible
bring it up and pointing your toes
throughout remember do not collapse on
the chair okay
stand tall be graceful good your hands
is just to be supporting you all right
very good
20 seconds break and we want to repeat
the entire workout again so it's going
to be a narrow to a wide squat all right
so remember point your toes out okay the
burn should be should really be on your
quads all right so put the upper body
stand tall let's now place our hands in
front squat down up up good down and out
very good by placing your hands in front
you should feel the work on your left
arm as well squat down and push it out
down and out very good going step out in
out in and out good pushing your knees
to the corner last few more last one
more and come back up okay your favorite
tiptoe all right so Stan wide all right
tiptoe bring your hands up this time
okay and really find your balance
Titanic or suck your belly in and let's
go as many as you can pull your knees
out good remember do not collapse your
upper body should be upright and you
should really feel the burn your legs
your thighs should be shaking that is
absolutely fine you know when when your
body is shaking you know that the
workout is good for you and it's working
good stand tall
push it up up push it out up if this is
tiring bring your hands in front out up
out and up good keep going
just one more and back up okay single
leg lunge all right so we've worked on
our right side let's change and work on
our left side this time so bring your
chair behind of you take a white step
forward with your left leg bring your
right knee right leg up okay
look forward down and push it up good
down and up
there you go good job
you might find that you might struggle
on one side more than the other okay
find your balance slow it down try to
bend your knee as low as you can
if this is too much for you then just do
small mini lunges okay done it up down
and up good last few more look straight
ahead
very good that's one more up and good
okay so this time place your chair on
the opposite side okay so left leg up
I'm gonna find a little bit more space
left leg up right leg to the side okay
and this is going to be a side lunge all
right let's go
push your butt back squeeze up down and
up
very good down and up so count one two
push it up good one two and up very good
one two push it up nice and slow and
power up push it up good upper body
facing front control good feel the print
on your right glute and your right nice
oh and you are done okay alright grab
hold of the chair all right
place it right in front of you and we've
done the work on our left leg now let's
change side and work on our right leg so
drive your right leg up okay balance on
your left drive it up kick it back
squeeze your gluts drive it in squeeze
all right good squeeze
and just slightly lean your body forward
bend the standing knee good we should
add squeeze pull it for at least one
count right at the top knee in up and up
one more up and now ten pulses one two
three four five six come on keep going
seven eight nine ten and bring it back
done okay
all right the other side okay okay so
this time we want to drive your right
knee up and kick it out to the sides
okay one final workout and you will get
a one-minute break all right let's go
hands by your waist up kick it out
good up and out driving right knee as
high as can balance on your left leg up
and point your toes okay
be grateful good point
up and point very good you are almost at
the end of your first circuit point
low-impact but it's such a great toning
workout really to firm up the legs
that's one more point and just shake it
out okay all right that is the end of
the first circuit which is on your lower
body take your 1 minute break and for
the second circuit we want to work on
our upper body as well as our car so
keep it up hydrated
[Music]
okay twenty more seconds break and we're
moving on to the second circuit which is
going to be working on your upper body
as well as your core strength all right
okay so the first workout is going to be
elevated push-up so we want to be using
your chair
step back support your upper body and
what are we to do is lower yourself down
try to reach your chest towards the
chair and push yourself back up for
those of you who struggle to do a full
push-up this is actually a great way to
start off with okay even if this is too
time for you then why not try it on the
wall to begin with alright so start by
performing elevator push-up and
eventually you can get down onto the
floor and perform a full push-up a few
more give me four more one two three
four okay one more all right and fight
good okay working on our triceps or more
commonly known as our bean going okay so
what are we to do is place your chair
and step at the front of your chair
place your palms on the chair with your
fingers pointed forward okay and we want
to get into tricep dips
so lower yourself down and push yourself
back up all right Laura step down and
push yourself back up okay you want to
make sure that your back is close to the
chair all right so don't do this this is
wrong your butt should be close to the
chair lower yourself down and push
yourself back up and your elbows should
be pointing backwards so do not spread
your elbows out put it back and lower
yourself okay if this is too difficult
you can take and bring your heels closer
to your body if this is too easy
then push it further away from your body
and lower yourself and push yourself
back up this is a really good tricep
workout do it more frequently and it
will really turn your triceps
okay now the fun part sit down on your
chair we're going to work on our core
knee
[ __ ] okay again support your upper body
and your bum on the chairs drive your
legs forward okay what are we to do is
alternate the knee right left right left
okay so drive your knee close to your
chest lean back slightly make sure you
don't have one of those chairs that will
roll away all right
so drive it in crunch it in crunch okay
as you crunch drive your upper body a
little bit forward do the work on your
lower abs as well as your upper abs
point a toast crunch good keep going and
breathe
last one Laura and okay all right still
working on our car do you remember the
warm-up we did well basically we want to
be doing the same thing all right except
this time I way to challenge yourself
and bring both legs up all right so it's
gonna be elbow to your knee okay
challenge yourself let's go bring both
legs up cross crunch good elbow to knee
if this is too difficult then you can
rest both feet on the floor this is
going to target more of the obliques
good keep going
hence that's what I say this is a really
good total body workout just using the
chair you have at home
crunch okay find your balance do you not
swing too much find that core strength
good twist and twist last two more one
more and rest it out all right
good now we want to be facing the chair
okay so place the chair in front of you
it's going to be mountain climbers again
for those of you who struggle to perform
a full model climber on the floor
you can't start off by doing an elevated
mountain climber so support a upper body
drafyn knee close to the chair okay so
back
flat and drive the knee to the chair
good one step at a time feel the work on
your core and do the work on your lower
back as well good keep going
and breathe out out and in all right for
the last 10 seconds we want to speed it
up slightly okay that's one more and
let's go speed up the mountain climber
last 10 seconds keep going push it oh
it's burning keep going one two and done
okay
final call work out as well as for your
glutes lie down okay this is going to be
a hip bridge but it's going to be a
little bit more challenging as we want
to place both feet on the chair all
right and all the way to do is drive
your butt up squeeze it right at the top
do the work and hamstrings lower it down
and up all right
you will really feel more engagement on
your glutes and your hamstrings and just
rest your heels on the chair push it all
the way up and slowly back down up holy
for two-count and down whoa up and down
okay let's pause the right other top
stay one to posit three through the
burns four five six seven and eight
okay lower yourself back down come back
up and it's back to the first workout
okay which is great to be elevated
push-ups all right let's do this strong
chest strong shoulders strong arms
let's go down and up okay as close as
you can to the chair good tighten your
core do not Pike your butt up okay nice
and easy one two down and push us up
back up
halfway there breathe out as you come up
okay breathe in breathe out push it up
straight body alright get into a high
plank as you push yourself back up up
last two more down one more up and very
very good job okay it's going to be
tricep dips
alright shake it a little bit rest if
you need to let's work on our triceps
get rid of that flabby bingo wings okay
so pumps with your fingers pointed
forward close to your body remember keep
your back close to the chair okay
do not drive your butt far away from the
chair if this is too easy
take your heels forward straighten your
legs down and up and remember the most
important is to drive both elbows back
do not spread them lower yourself down
crew shop very good this is one of my
favourite tricep workout it is so simple
but it is so effective just strengthen
your triceps and to tone them up that's
two more push it up oh and up all right
very good
okay now let's sit down on your chair
knee tucks okay
alternate between left and right knee
all right
just support it upper body let's go both
legs up right left right left good
lean back slightly okay do not laugh in
your body collapse backward just a
little bit I remember don't hold onto
the chair too tight
okay all the work should be coming from
your core all right good
okay now let's go double me okay it's
going to be more of a challenge but
let's do it out and in out and in give
me two more
laughs one more and check it out okay
cross crunch okay get your body ready
roll your shoulders if you need to it's
going to be the right elbow to the left
knee
both hands up okay do not hunch forward
this way all right both legs up hands by
your head crunch and drive your knee
close to your body all right remember do
not collapse your upper body forward
lean back slightly good need to elbow
knee to elbow
I would rather you slow down the workout
then rush through the workout and con's
complete a proper rap okay good
keep going twist twist do the work on
your obliques twist and twist that's two
more on each side
that's one more ah okay
all right mountain climber okay so let's
face your chair all right
remember start in a high plank position
I don't want to see this okay
this is not a mountain climber stuck in
a high plank position with your back
flat driver knee close to the chair all
right nice and easy slow but feel the
contraction on your core remember again
do not like your butt up
good keep going alternating bring the
speed up slightly step back into a high
plank good ooh this is hard work
all right last ten seconds give me eight
count okay go one two three four five
six seven eight nine okay all right okay
you know this final workout all right
lie down on the floor okay if this is
too difficult you can on me to the chair
and do it without the chair place both
heels on the chair pumps just by your
body and let's go drive the glutes up
your hips up back down up into a nice
straight line back down and squeeze
squeeze your glutes squeeze the
hamstrings control it down and up good
don't just let your body fall nice and
control and no resting straight back up
and back down
very good again if you want to take this
workout to the next level you can play
some weight on your body okay let's go
pulses one two three four five that's
five six seven eight nine and ten and
lower yourself back down
oh my gosh very very well done okay now
come back up and just grab your chair
and we want to just sit down okay you
are done all right that was a total body
workout using a chair okay now I just
want you to just stretch it out a little
bit bring your left leg on top of your
right leg okay and just reach down and
just feel the stretch on your left Lutz
as well as a hip flexor
and reach as far as you can if you can't
touch the floor that's fine just hold
onto your knees reach down and breathe
good we're not rushing your cooldown is
just as important as your workout app
swap right leg on top of your left and
reach down my right thighs my right
glutes it's tighter okay look forward
all right now spread your legs apart
okay sit at the edge of your chair and I
want to just reach down okay
feel the stretch on your inner thighs
good reach down lean forward and stretch
all right and now just twist okay
body upright grab hold of a chair twist
to one side release twist to the
opposite side and breathe and now just
roll your shoulders okay rotate left to
right and very very very well done that
was a thirty minute hold the body chair
workout okay if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up the get
your family and friends to join you in
this workout because this is a
low-impact workout and it is safe for
almost everybody get them to join you
and do this workout at home be sure to
share this video on tag me in your
workouts and subscribe to my youtube
channel okay and I do have a lot more
workout videos workout challenges meal
plans recipes as well as nutritional
tips on my youtube channel and I will
see you next time remember to get up and
get moving at home are the best